ali sadler
alan grant
you didn't come out all this way just to
catch up now did you
you coming or what
great to see you all i get nostalgic
excited even watching the first jurassic
park i get weepy
the chills do you get the same thing i
mean how good does this feel to be
reunited
it feels amazing
yeah yeah it's
it's really
immensely rewarding that's wonderful
yeah we've had a continuum now for a few
decades and i must say
during the shooting of the last movie it
was during covert and we were all you
know huddled huddled up
hugger what does that mean it's like a
mugger it's meant to all cuddled up you
know we were hugging just sheltering
from the storm but i felt closer in a
way we've got i felt we all got closer
than ever we had been we got chummier
and and spent many hours
talking and walking music playing music
playing music we sang a little look up
on your music night on your things
you'll see a couple of snippets of us
singing some old tunes he's a wonderful
he's got a wonderful voice you do you do
please ignore that
so what was the day like
the first day the three of you stepped
back on set together
what was that moment like for all of you
well i'll break it well i just remember
arriving i've told this before i
remember arriving and they had already
gotten there to the hotel and they yeah
and they did that they were up on like a
balcony because it's a grand we were at
the grand at the langley
and these two were like that math and
shields maybe my luggage was in the car
and they were like that i was like
hi
hi
that was great and then the first day
was um the seat you haven't seen it yet
and i won't give anything away we're all
in a vehicle and there's uh it's uh
it's a very it's life and death and uh
and we have we have to see that was my
first time i think that was the first
day yeah and the first scene
yeah i think so
in the jeep yeah we trying with an
effect
we were dealing with and there was some
improvisation like
yeah that was fun and my kids were there
watching
it was the only scene they they watched
and i said oh look and watch this anyway
so now i
in the jurassic world
things that things happen to vehicles
you know what i mean
it usually it doesn't end well
that's all i'm going to say
but i remember
colin
you know being in the direction of the
scene
and then saying it hit him
that our characters were there
all together again and
that he got
moved
and we um i texted uh steve in a
photograph
of all of us together what'd you say he
got very emotional he said he said it
made him uh yeah
yeah so it is yeah a lovely family story
i know you said back in the day sam that
you all became the masters of amazement
because you were the first to do a
blockbuster cg film and you had to react
off of something off of just whatever it
was
have you perfected it reperfected it who
amongst the three of you is the biggest
master of amazement and coming back this
time how different did it feel did it
feel sort of like the last time or does
it feel completely like something new um
there's nothing like the first time is
there
when it comes when it comes to ore and
you know that stuff i'd nominate laura
dern as being the number one just for
shock and awe i second that emotion yeah
oh there's nobody nobody can do that i
will say that i will say
that
being the original cast
putting ourselves in circumstances where
then friends would ask us what was that
like you had nothing to look at and now
every actor we know has had to do this
in a movie
but we felt like we were the first ones
you know pretending at something that
wasn't there and then walking onto a set
with other people have who've been doing
this for three movies oh yeah and
watching bryce also
scream in her shock and awe
i don't know she might have taken the
cake yeah and how was that being with
the whole cast together because i know
bryce really really couldn't wait to
work with you i know they were all
really excited i don't know if this is
true or not that you maybe asked chris
you were like i have to be an action
star now back then i didn't have to be
an action star you talked about hitting
the gym like talk about that sort of
interaction with the new cast and look
they're just such sweethearts that's the
first thing
and they were so welcoming to us and
just generous and chris pratt is a
genuine
action hero and that's something we've
never really done you know we're we're
kind of
you know
we're where are you
no no i mean the truth is we're kind of
uh nerds in very uh unpleasant
situations now look here i don't know
what what the
and i've never really properly
considered what do you do to be an
action hero and it's a whole bunch of
skills
that i was that i'd never really
considered i i find him completely
awesome jeff goldblum is a great action
hero thank you
but pratt is another level okay
are you listening to this you are
actually don't have your light under a
bushel you are actually you may not know
it but let me se i'll give you a
doctor's excuse right now
you are
not only heroic because of your genuine
integrity
and
uh magnificence but a true man of the
earth you should see him on the farm
with animals uh
he's a doctor alan grant's taking action
an exemplar of the species yes and
you've named
animals after
your co-stars this is true yes
great pride uh i haven't told jeff this
yet but his
jeff goldblum the ram has retired oh
retired you mean is that a euphemism
no he's retired he's he went off to
another farm and uh i'm sure he's doing
good work not like my dog my my dog when
my mom said i said to you yes yes the
dog's gonna be okay we shipped it off to
a farm upstate pennsylvania he's gonna
be fine yeah mine went to a farm too so
laura how were your scenes with bryce
amazing amazing i mean we had so much
fun together and like chris
you know they're so generous in the way
things have worked for them in these
films and working on stunts that bryce
would stand at the monitor when i was
doing a stunt
and be very protective and like oh you
know what if you did this and like maybe
if you go closer there and like so
excited
to
support her actors in every way
and i'll never forget i mean when we
have this end sequence all of us
together and there's hardcore running
um chris would take us through our uh
stunt prep
our warm-up
exercises so he was much like our our
trainer because we were the kind of
action heroes in the first movie where
if we were honest it was going to feel
real and true and then you do things
like pull your quadricep muscle and like
tear something in your arm because we
never thought about like
you know
warming up and preparing for the sprint
i had a dark moment
i have to tell you
there is a point in the film where we're
all together and we all have to run like
crazy
to avoid being killed and we're waiting
for the cameras to to to get ready and
pratt is warming up he's stretching you
know and mama do is running on the spot
he's sprinting and dewanda wise has some
rubber bands and she's popping up
jeff goldblum is doing his jazz dance
and and she's athletic i mean we all
know she's athletic she's she's
stretching too oh my god and i'm going
i'm about 20 years older than anyone
else
in this film
i'm not sure if i'm going to be able to
make it a cross i think i will this is
the time i get eaten
by an animatronic dinosaur because i
don't think i can run as fast as anyone
and they're so fit and they're so young
and i'm going to die
luckily
what happened i kept up you sure did
you won the race what's the lyric in
that song ah yes i remember it well
and he says am i getting old dear oh no
not you
and that reminds me what you are so good
off the cuff
your moments from the original film have
become
internet memes
are there callbacks in this show just
you
wait henry higgins just you wait oh yeah
you're gonna see a couple of uh
hopefully delicious tasty uh
morsels marshalls
um
yes yes what was i gonna say oh i know
what i was gonna say about the new cast
you know in my humble opinion they're
not only great actors and
masterful action athletes you know but
they're all given to um
characters filled with a leadership
qualities i mean really brett bryce is
an amazing director and producer and was
really a group
thinker and nurturer and leader and so
is chris
and so are you you guys obviously
leaders it's a it's a rare group of
people who have this
fine uh nobility you know okay now i
need you to toot your own horn a little
bit i need to hear about these moments
that are gonna happen in this film so
there are so there's a few callbacks
and some new deliciousness yeah yeah i
can't give them away and hopefully like
you were saying they'll be well received
and and enjoyed
for what we intended but yeah they're
you know colin trevaro and emily
carmichael who co-wrote the script very
powerful and brilliant voice um yes
found things they wanted to i think
overall satisfy the viewer and fan from
the original and there are a couple of
things that happen that we hope will be
a little bit delightful um that remind
us of moments and things that happened
that are off the cuff and improvised by
you as well and
hysterical really yeah like which ones i
can't tell okay
but you've all seen the film oh yeah
just a few nights ago we all sat for the
first time a few nights ago and what was
your reaction
i have never made so much noise in the
film i was going whoa the oh oh ow oh
it's always unbelievable it's
unbelievable i have never seen an action
movie that comes anywhere near this yeah
i felt as if
i had revealed myself to myself
and i was drenched and purged
wow i think that's the best review of a
film i've ever heard
that's very unusual and you look at the
person and you open your eyes
going back a bit like was it was it at
all a difficult decision for you all to
come back or was it like how did it all
did you call each other how did it all
sort of converge and come together
that's right we did talk nobody's asked
that question
yeah yeah yeah i was in italy i thought
we should make you know we thought we
should make contact let's have fun did
we how do you feel what do you think
talking to stephen and frank marshall
yeah what do you think and then during
the during the filming we would uh just
between us we would get together from
time to time and just huddle up and say
how are you doing how are you doing
anything we need to uh you know do why
do you think this has endured so long
why do fans love it so much why is why
are people so excited to see this film
to see the culmination and see the three
of you back together we've always had
great women here's one right beside us
we've always had uh terrific villains
campbell scott in this film is is a
fabulous verb
wayne knight all those guys we've always
had great kids
isabella sermon is on this one
spectacular people die spectacularly uh
r.i.p
they die on time they get ripped apart
in swimming pools you know uh
but there's a sort of um magic thing
that um dinosaurs bring that that i
don't know why children are so
fascinated by dinosaurs but they
absolutely are they just really dig them
they sure are my two boys six and four
and they're dinosaurs all over the house
and that's not just because oh no dad
has been in a movie no there's dinosaurs
everywhere kids do love them but i must
say it occurs to me now that you've
brought it up um it's just lucky that we
that we play these characters that have
created lasting interest crichton wrote
michael crichton wrote interesting and
good characters but
steven spielberg you know made a movie
that you can't be
good unless
the director is good and he made a movie
that for
one reason or another his
brilliance and genius and talent and all
the elements came together and made you
know
several things in that movie that a lot
of people seem to be
enchanted by and the thing that i'm so
moved by is when fans have come up to me
knowing we've made this film
and they say i will never forget i was
10. i was 12. my mom brought me my
brother and i saw the stories of the
first time they saw this movie and how
obsessed they are
with the idea of this spectacle of
seeing these dinosaurs and the
coexistence of humans and dinosaurs and
their whole dream is that now they get
to bring their children to the thing
that meant so much to them
and that's
you know that's it's hard for a
franchise to get to do that in the same
way um and it's you know really really
fun yeah the technology of that first
cgi stuff that was new at the time was
something that not only we were
you know amazed by but uh you know got
audiences just at that right time
wow so yeah that was part of the
experience
you